[Music]
in life
we learn different things from different
people
this is one of the values of having a
diverse set of friends
a lot of people turn to my friend annie
because she's a successful
retail executive for me however i
learned what it means to be generous
for manny i learn so much from her
and so i thought the generous thing to
do would be to share annie
with you this is a bit of optimism
annie do you know what i wanted to talk
to you about
i want to talk about generosity and the
reason i want to talk to you about
generosity
is because i think you're the most
generous person i've ever met in my
entire
life oh my god and i've met some pretty
generous people
you give of yourself in a way that i've
never seen and i've seen you around your
other friends
everyone feels that about you i don't
know how you have the time and energy
to give that much of yourself to so many
people everyone i know
who knows you loves you
because you make us feel special
you make us feel like we're the only
person that matters in the world
and the reason i wanted to talk to you
about it is because i want to learn how
to do that
because i don't know how to do that
did you learn it well first of all
i don't even know how to respond to that
other than i think you're crazy and i
appreciate it very
much i think that as with anything it's
a learned
action and i would say that hokias it
might sound
starts with my parents so i have been
given the example from
the minute i was born until today of
just
how that can make you feel and how you
can make somebody else feel no matter if
it's
something super small or something
actually quite big
making an effort makes all the
difference in the world and i think that
that affects anything and everything you
have in your life whether it be friends
a husband boyfriend whatever or work
colleagues or the guy in the gas station
um i i do believe it it costs nothing
for me it doesn't take an extra effort i
watched
the selflessness of my parents
we grew up with not a ton of money and
the church was our place to go and
it didn't matter who needed help
everybody showed up and i think showing
up is a really big deal
i think showing up makes all the
difference in the world
and you can't buy that how did you learn
to anticipate
because you're you're good at that like
i'll say something in passing
and you'll bring it up or it'll show up
weeks later do you make mental notes did
you physically write these things down
so if i go back to really early
childhood i was
taught and i observed at a very early
age that
anything is possible and if you want
something you can go and get it
and i watched again my parents or those
around my parents who
if they wanted a law changed or the
priest to pay attention my mother went
and slept in front of the church for
whatever it took for the priest to come
outside and finally talk to her
you always have time you're an
incredibly busy person
you're up early early morning and you're
work too late and you're always on the
phone you're always on zoom you're
always
talking to all you know all parts of the
world and yet if i call you
you take the call like you always have
time
and i'm not the only person who calls
you
and i'm not the only person who loves
you and i'm not the only person who you
give to
there's only 24 hours in a day you seem
to get 28 out
[Laughter]
you know it fills my soul as much as it
does
yours or anybody else i have the
absolute
gift of having a large group of friends
and people around me that
are extraordinary people starting with
you and i could make a really strong
list of these people which i'm very
fortunate to have
it would be very difficult not to take a
call because it makes
me feel better it's not for you it's
it's a selfish thing to do to take a
call from you
or other friends and i do find
in this last bit of time especially at
times strong personalities like
you and i and those that give more than
say others or it's more common
or easier sometimes forget that we need
something
and somebody like you and others in my
life
have really shown up in these last
months when
you know something's happened or you
know that i'm working too hard or i'm
tired or whatever
so i do think that i've established or
i've received a very
good give and take the bucket is more
than half full
i'm not constantly giving out do you
know how to ask for help
no you make me address that question
because you're always in giving mode
yeah i think that's
probably one of the negatives being
available is your cup runs out your gas
runs out
you know you are going to get tired i
have a pretty strong threshold but
that is probably one of the drawbacks
for any of it for sure
the thing that i find really interesting
there seems to be a precursor to
generosity
and you touched upon it just a second
ago which is gratitude
which is very interesting before you can
be generous you have to be grateful
the question is if somebody's generous
without gratitude it's almost artificial
right it's almost because they feel they
have to be or it's
it's because they want something or it's
calculated
it may not be calculated in a nefarious
way
but just sort of like this is what i'm
supposed to do i
i classify myself as a as a good person
and this is what good
it's almost overly selfish
but what i find so interesting is your
ability to be generous
starts with the gratitude you have for
the people around you
and generosity is not actually the thing
you do
it's almost the result of being uh
grateful
does that make sense yeah it does it
does i
i can remember very very early on you
know as with anything when you
achieve something that's positive it's
an endorphin and you feel that much
better and you go forward and and you do
things
it leaps you forward on a lot of ways
and i have had
so many experiences where i have left
forward
obviously i think you have to be the one
to take advantage of what's being put in
front of you or
to also open the curtains and look
outside to say hold on what else is out
there
i try to lead with gratitude i can also
be
somewhat critical because i i also find
that i'm generous
but i also am careful with that as you
say there's 24 hours in a day
and i like to believe that what i have
in my life is a huge
rippling pond and as you show up for
something
you're going to get 10 fold out of it
because it ripples out
and i do think that you can also show up
for people that don't expect it
not always do people realize it or are
grateful for it but
a lot of times you can change somebody
by the investment that you make to make
a difference
a lot of people are very cynical about
generosity you know it's kind of like
some people who are very guarded with
their emotions
because they fear being hurt why would i
put myself out there why would i be
vulnerable i'm just going to get hurt
right and so they walk around with this
with a wall up and i think some people
are very cynical about generosity as
well well what if i'm generous
you know where somebody just takes
advantage of me could happen
i'm sure it's happened to you you know
where they just take and take and take
because they know you'll give i can't be
calculated about it i don't want to
think about it long enough
then i won't do it if i have to then put
it in perspective and
and weigh it out to see whether or not i
prefer to leave
with the gratitude foot and assume my
gut instincts are probably better than
not
and so if i make a mistake you know what
i'll move on
this is what i like about friendship
right or any relationship a business
relationship as well
which is good relationships are
egalitarian not equal
equal means i cook you cook i do the
dishes you do the dishes i take out the
garbage you take out the garbage
that's equal egalitarian is i'll cook
you do the dishes
i'll take out the garbage you empty the
dishwasher that's egalitarian where it
feels balanced that we're not doing the
same thing
and i think healthy relationships are
like that where
you know i don't walk around a little
notebook with all the things i've done
for you and all the things you've done
for me
annie i did 10 things for you this week
and you've only done one
come on what kind of friendship do we
have here right that's not what happens
and for me if i did a hundred things for
you
and you did nothing for me but i had the
absolute confidence
that the one time i'm gonna need you no
matter what day or what time
i know without a shadow of a doubt you
will be there the whole thing
feels completely balanced i agree
and i've made this mistake i've made
this mistake in my own
life and my own friendships i give and
give and give and it is very unbalanced
where it's not balanced equally or
egalitarian
yeah where i came to the realization
with some friends that if i'd never
picked up the phone i don't think i'd
ever hear
from them again for the rest of my life
all the energy was one-sided
yep i hear you and i sort of like
thought to myself
i enjoy their company but do i have
absolute confidence that they'll be
there for me when i need them
no it's not even in doubt a million
percent i agree
and so then the question i have to ask
myself is is it still appropriate for me
to be very generous to those people
all the time the conclusion i came up
with was no which sounds a little harsh
but my argument was i've got limited
energy and limited time
and i love giving and i don't need to
get back
but i need to have the confidence that a
friend is actually a friend
it's not something transactional yeah
yeah
did you have a mentor growing up oh yeah
there was a woman by the name of marie
lameck so
marie was one of my mother's best
friends and
she was a little bit on the nutty side
she was somebody who always treated me
like an adult no matter if i was six
seven
ten or whatever and at about 15 we were
at church one day and she said
you know i was really mad with the world
and wanting to get out of here and go
and run things somewhere else
and uh she asked me to come over to her
house gave me a gin and tonics out in
the backyard and talked about life and
she she really got me she really
understood that
i was gonna run and that i needed to
wait a few minutes
i couldn't leave yet but she listened to
me she
she heard me she saw me you didn't get
that at home
i know i'm the oldest of five i was you
know washing dishes putting people in
vans taking them to ballet class
you know you name it my dad was a
salesman
they were very involved with everything
all of us were in various
activities it was very difficult to
juggle five kids that are pretty much
one after the other and i'm also not an
easy character as a kid i was a real
pain in the butt
my mother would use a different word but
tell me something you've done in your
career that you absolutely love doing
it doesn't matter if it was a commercial
success or not but if like if everything
you did
professionally were like this one thing
you'd be the happiest person alive
wow i would say opening
the outlet shopping center that we
opened in italy
uh after i'd been with the company for
about seven or eight years i asked to be
responsible to open a
an actual village from the construction
all the way through etc
and they threw me in there i had no idea
what i was doing which i've always done
i've always been been in situations
where i've been thrown into something i
don't know how to do
and i love the challenge of it but this
was an amazing
a huge challenge and i mean i'll tell
you just
one story it was 42 outside which is
about 104
every day and these guys were working 24
hours a day
brick layers you name it and i could see
how hot it was so
i said we're going to need to get this
done there's only one way we're going to
get it done is if these guys are happy
and healthy and
moving fast so we started with one
pallet of water by the third day we were
up to about 4 700 bottles of cold water
every day because i said they have to be
cold they can't be worn
then i decided we needed to find
popsicles for these guys
so i went around to some of the bars all
i could find was about 14 popsicles and
that wasn't going to work so this woman
overheard me
and she ended up long story short giving
me 4 000 popsicles a day
three times a day she delivered them we
went into business with four different
pizza makers we made all the pizzas
in their off hours so that the pizza
makers could
do the work without interrupting their
normal business so
the lady with the popsicles came and
brought me a plant at christmas and said
i just want to thank you my family's
never been on vacation and because we
were able to
bring you all these popsicles we're
going on vacation
and the pizza guys they were able to
open two more stores and at the end of
the day though for me
the thing that was great about it is all
the teams that were there and there were
you know a hundred and some odd people
helping me open this place
everybody could feel that it was a
popsicle it was a bottle of water
it was a pizza which is any single
person
can can afford or have right and you
could feel
that momentum and that infectiousness
that goes with
the guy who's building the wall over in
the back when you walk up with a bottle
of water and he looks at you and says
you mean that's for me you're going to
give me a bottle of water
it's a bottle of water but it's freaking
hot outside it was quite the commotion
and it was probably the most
exhilarating experience i've ever had
what specifically made it exhilarating
you've done a lot of exhilarating things
in your
spectacular career what specifically
about this one thing
did you consider exhilarating every
single person and there were hundreds
of construction guys there were over 100
on the value retail team there were
i don't know how many suppliers involved
we had people that were coming to work
with us at the end
that i had no idea who they worked for
and they didn't care who they worked for
they were running around and if they saw
somebody that needed some help
they just said i got a hammer hold on
i'll be right back the energy was
palatable it was infectious and
i don't know how you would feel if you
were an actor and you won an oscar or
you clowned mine at everest i don't know
that i've ever had that feeling before
because it was an energy that was
tangible
and it affected a lot of people and by
the way we opened on time
tell me an early specific happy
childhood memory
i was a cheerleader that'll make you
laugh and
uh my father was the
football coach for the grade school
and we won state championship our team
won
the cheerleader championship for best
cheerleaders in texas
and we won the best football team in
texas and if you've ever watched friday
night lights
double it by 500 it's unbelievable
and of all the things you did as a kid
what is it specifically about this one
that stands out to you
you know it's kind of similar to the one
i just said about the shopping center it
was about a
really large group of people being super
happy having worked
really hard and everybody showed up to
do their jobs
and it was a united happy
because i was on a team of cheerleaders
my dad was coaching a team
you know and it was everybody was just
this this combustion of happy was
unbelievable
but you the combustion of happy you've
had combustion of happy
i'm sure before what what produced the
combustion of happy that you
again that you that you're talking about
with such fondness now
well i we achieved the impossible
because if you know me
being a cheerleader isn't exactly the
first place you put me as a description
and
that was quite the achievement that i
was able to do it
and then to win something on top of it
was pretty extraordinary
but it was really hard work it was one
of those things where you you know you
had to practice and practice and
practice
and at the end you could see the payoff
and so
the investment was well worth it it was
different than other things
it was a longer period of time too which
is very similar to the
the shopping center you know some things
if you get a good math test
great it's a little bit more of a
shorter period of time this was
something that was a big investment it
was a
big anticipation and we got there and we
absolutely made it what i love about
these two stories
it goes back to generosity again there's
a lot of giving that was happening
you made this fantastic distinction of
working hard over a long period of time
to do something big
versus the feeling you get when you just
you know get a good grade on your math
test
and i think that there's a correlation
to the kind of generosity that you
embody
which is there's short-term generosity
saying good morning
saying thank you and then there's this
more
invested generosity where you you don't
just
do something spontaneously for someone
which is very generous
but rather there's an invested
generosity like
i have to solve a problem in order to be
generous like how am i going to get
these folks
not just water but cold water in the
high 90s and
low hundreds every day how am i going to
figure out to get that many pizzas when
the pizza
stores can't make that many pizzas
because they have a other business to
run
anybody else would have said popsicles
yeah we couldn't find them
oh well we'll just stick with the water
but you were determined to solve these
problems
you had a hair brained idea i'm going to
get a popsicle
and you would stop at nothing until you
figure out the problem and the solution
you found
created more generosity because you
helped
these this other person build an entire
business out of this one project
there's an invested generosity that i
find fascinating
that you actually spend time and energy
away from
the generous act to source and find and
ask and research and dig
and now i'm sort of understanding the
intensity of what it's like to be on the
receiving end of your generosity
which is when it happens it's
overwhelming because it's not actually
the thing
that you did in that moment it's not the
little gift that you've given me i know
in that moment
the reason it's emotional is because i
know how much work you had to do
or pay attention or take notes for that
little box to arrive that day that may
or may not be anything
you know it might be something small i
know everything that had to happen to
get me to that point
yeah no it makes sense i i hear what
you're saying i guess
i don't consciously think of it that way
but when you asked me to relay the story
then i do think about it i could give
you
you know many many other examples like
that because my mind is a time in action
calendar
then it sounds calculated but it's not
no i understand it what i find so
impressive
is just your ability and you're a very
good listener
you know i've been in group things with
you and you're very quiet you know
you're in a room of big personalities
and you have a big personality and yet
you take in the room
and i'll give you one stupid example
during the pandemic we were
both at a zoom dinner party and
one of the people at our zoom dinner
party was eating luminati's pizza
and everybody on the call everybody on
the zoom meeting went oh my god it's the
best and i went
i've never tried it and that was it we
moved on to the next thing
and three weeks later six luminati's
pizzas
show up at my house from you
no no no nothing they just show up
and talk about the generosity that you
know the way it flows for you i have
since
gifted loom walnutty's pizza
to multiple people but
it's that kind of little thing anybody
else would say oh my god simon you
should try them
and that would be it we'd move on but
you at the end of that dinner party
you got them for me i mean it seems
silly that one's not
you know heavily researched per se but
that's it's just the paying attention
and wanting to fill these little gaps in
someone's life experience
it's kind of what you do and i love the
gratitude i love that it seeps with
gratitude
and this is where i started i said to
you i don't have the energy that you
have to be generous and
what i'm learning is i need to start
each day with gratitude yeah
yeah and then i will you know there's an
analogy there's a connection i'm making
here
so i've always my whole life been
very bad with remembering people's names
terrible at it
i mean i'll meet them and like five
minutes later i can't remember their
name
and i've just believed it was some
failing of my own brain
and i would say that i'm like i'm really
sorry i'm just really bad with names and
faces
you know and somebody pointed out to me
that
we can do things that matter to us and
they challenged me they said
maybe you don't remember people's names
because they don't matter to you and i
thought that was
like a dagger through my heart you know
and i know how
special it makes people feel when you
remember their name
and so i sort of made this decision that
of course i want to make people feel
seen and heard and special and if if i
only have to remember a name
i'll do that and now when i meet someone
a stranger someone will come up to me
and say that there they admire my work
for example
i'll immediately ask them their name we
can have a nice lovely long conversation
and at the end i'll thank them and say
their name again and
the number of times they're surprised
that i remember their name we
acknowledge them
yeah and i have become pretty good at
remembering people's names because now i
know
it matters to them it's no longer about
me oh i'm not good at remembering names
blah blah blah
as soon as i was able to make it
something generous
as soon as i was able to make the
remembering of a name a generous act
it actually became a lot easier so to
what you do i was
confounded how you find all the time and
energy but because it's born out of
generosity the time and energy shows up
yes yeah i do believe it's it's very
infectious when you make people happy
yeah so i've learned something today
that you can only be truly generous to
others
if you are first grateful for the things
that they do for you
or that life has given you that you have
to start your day
with gratitude and then the rest of the
day you will have the energy
to be generous but i think that we also
have to feel that gratitude
i i did something nice for somebody
recently
and they showed no gratitude to me and i
remember thinking to myself
well i won't do that again so i yeah
so i actually think that gratitude is
important
all the time like the more gratitude we
feel from people
the more generous we want to become and
the more grateful we are uh the more
people will be
generous to us yeah i think the moral of
the story is
if we could all learn to just be a
little more
grateful for the things we have for the
people around us
and everyone can find something to be
grateful for every single day without a
doubt
and the world would become a much more
generous place completely agree
you're the best well i'm just grateful
for you
[Laughter]
you win
oh annie i adore you
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other